Bienvenidos a enlace andino en esta
edición desde Lima Perú hoy hablaremos
sobre la caída de la natalidad en este
país un estudio realizado por el
organismo Estatal de registro civil
afirma que los nacimientos han
disminuido en el período de 2012 a 2021
en más del 57% debido al decrecimiento
de matrimonios y por la edad promedio en
que las peruanas y los peruanos deciden
casarse según el sector salud en la
nación andina se registra un descenso de
la natalidad por voluntad propia y
además porque las parejas tienen mayor
acceso y disposición a métodos
anticonceptivos a esto se añade a que
las nuevas generaciones están decidiendo
tener cada vez menos hijos y si en el
futuro hay menos peruanos quién
sostendrá el país es la pregunta que se
hacen algunos funcionarios
[Música]
el Registro Nacional de identificación y
estado civil reniec reportó que los a
nivel nacional registran una tendencia
decreciente en los últimos nueve años el
organismo reveló que en el 2012 se
contabilizaron
738,945 alumbramientos mientras que de
enero a mayo de 2021 el registro fue de
318,007 para reniec la disminución de la
natalidad es producto del bajo número de
matrimonios en los últimos años en el
2020 solo se inscribieron 44,593 una
reducción casi al 50%, En comparación
con el 2019 con
84.738 casamientos vemos que las
personas deciden casarse mucho más tarde
mientras antes se casaban a los 30 años
ahora los hombres lo hacen a los 37 años
como edad promedio o a veces a los 38
mientras que las mujeres como edad
promedio se casan a los 33 o 34 sin duda
alguna los jóvenes muestran que deciden
apostar más por su desarrollo personal y
profesional también también y Esto hace
que tardíamente decidan casarse o tener
hijos sin embargo el Ministerio de salud
sostiene que reniec solo contabiliza el
registro de matrimonios y no considera
la encuesta Nacional de demografía que
analiza los nacimientos de hijos de
parejas unidas en casamiento en
convivencia además señala que la
fecundidad ha venido descendiendo en el
Perú en los últimos 35 años la
fertilidad descendió de 4,3 a 2,0 niños
por mujer según estadísticas oficiales
mientras que en los últimos cinco años
la fecundidad disminuyó en 20%. es decir
pasó de 2,5 a 2,0 bebés por mujer del
2015 al 2021 por otro lado el 78% de
mujeres unidas en matrimonio convivencia
de 15 a 49 años de edad usan
anticonceptivos de ellas el 57%, métodos
modernos y el 21,1 tradicionales los
registros de nacimientos si han
disminuido Lo que pasa que no lo podemos
relacionar completamente con la unión
formal que registra el reniec no sino
más bien tenemos que observarlo en todo
el contexto de las mujeres o las
personas que deciden o no tener hijos en
un momento determinado Y esa tasa que es
la que se mide es la que ha venido
disminuyendo progresivamente o sea no
podemos decir que ha sido una misión ha
venido progresivamente porque porque ha
mejorado el acceso a uso de métodos
anticonceptivos el país por ejemplo
ofrece métodos anticonceptivos de manera
gratuita de tal manera que y consejería
de tal manera que las mujeres y las
parejas pueden decidir de manera libre
en qué momento Y cuándo tener sus hijos
los especialistas también señalan que
Perú las costumbres han cambiado hoy los
jóvenes tienden a independizarse de sus
familias Se perfilan más por desarrollar
un proyecto de vida antes que ser padres
Stephanie Trujillo y Andrés Ramos se
hicieron novios en la universidad ambos
provienen de familias numerosas sin
embargo solo quieren tener un hijo
vamos pensamos en que primero tenemos
que realizarnos como personas tener lo
que hemos planificado ambos cada uno
Este con sus proyectos personales Y
también complementados con los de pareja
que podemos tener el futuro es una
preocupación para las autoridades que
calculan que quizás en unos 20 o 25 años
en Perú se produzcan pocos nacimientos y
gran parte de la población está
probablemente conformada por adultos o
adultos mayores
Quién va a sostener al Perú y lo que
está ocurriendo también es que tenemos
jóvenes que dentro de esta apuesta de
Desarrollo personal y profesional
deciden viajar al extranjero para hacer
algún tipo de estudios de maestría o de
doctorado y finalmente terminan también
quedándose allá y obviamente mostrando
todas sus capacidades y cualidades mire
tenemos ya más de un millón de peruanos
que se encuentran habitando fuera del
país y la mayor cantidad son mujeres
Mientras tanto la última encuesta
demográfica de salud familiar revela que
el 63,8% de las mujeres unidas en
matrimonio o convivencia no desean tener
más hijos Gracias por acompañarnos en
esta emisión de enlace andino desde Lima
Perú les invitamos a que nos envíen sus
sugerencias sobre temas que le gustaría
ver en nuestro programa sigan
disfrutando de la programación de
Francia 24 en español y hasta pronto